buenas tardes para todas y para todos mi
nombre es jesús emilio tuberquía vengo
de colombia del departamento de
antioquia municipio apartado
mi comunidad de paz manda muchos saludos
a todas y a todos muchos agradecimientos
por todos los que han participado para
coordinar el evento y facilitar la
presencia mía acá en el evento muchas
gracias
y mi comunidad de paz
fue
creada por campesinos
que de 1980 al 1997
y nos tocó vivir repetidas
desplazamientos forzados
estamos en una zona de confrontación
armada en colombia las de las más
confrontativas
y fue así como un grupo de campesinos
cansados de tanta violencia
pensamos en crear una comunidad neutral
un grupo de campesinos cientos de
campesinos que hemos sido desplazados
nos había tocado ver masacres muertes
selectivas e incendios de viviendas
robos de ganados etcétera
estos cientos de campesinos ya cansados
de la violencia de tantas violaciones a
los derechos humanos por parte de todos
los actores armados incluyendo la fuerza
política
nos vimos en esa obligación
de firmar una declaratoria para empezar
a visibilizar toda la grave violación a
los derechos humanos que se venían
cometiendo contra la población civil en
la zona y contra el campesinado
fue así como entonces
buscamos la iglesia católica
el obispo monseñor isaías duarte cancino
era el obispo y él nos colaboró para
firmar esta declaratoria buscamos varias
instituciones también para darle
visibilidad al proceso
dentro de todo esto porque era una zona
de confrontación
la fuerza pública fue la que más cometió
o ha cometido violaciones a los derechos
humanos
justificó entonces la muerte de muchas
mujeres de niños ancianos
y joven jóvenes jovencitas
porque cuando había confrontación
culpaba nos culpan era a nosotros los
civiles
y cualquiera de las partes nos
asesinaban a nosotros esto llevó a un
desplazamiento al casco urbano
del corregimiento y ahí empezamos a
reorganizarnos
a darle forma a la parte organizativa de
una comunidad neutral
estuvimos entonces los bloqueos
económicos no nos dejaban de entrar
alimentos habíamos dejado todo nos
habían desalojado de las tierras de
nuestras propiedades habíamos dejado
todo no teníamos que comer pero tampoco
nos dejaban comprar víveres en el
municipio de apartadó la fuerza pública
y los paramilitares tenían retenes todo
estaba militarizado
mataron a todos los comerciantes que
tenían pequeñas tiendas de víveres los
conductores que transportaban alimentos
al casco urbano
era una situación muy difícil para
nosotros
esto llevó a organizarnos mucho más para
poder resistir
a esta grave situación que se venía
presentando
fue así como entonces nos organizamos
más comunitariamente para hacer grupos
de trabajo
y poder volver a recoger algo de las
fincas para poder
sembrar de nuevo
y empezar a tener alimentos
al inicio que roja internacional nos
acompañó para esto para poder empezar
ese trabajo es el proceso
son situaciones
horrible los que nos ha tocado pero
gracias a
al acompañamiento y a la solidaridad
internacional
que es la que nos ha permitido
sobrevivir
así es como hemos empezado a reconstruir
todo el tejido social que había sido
destruido por parte de la fuerza pública
y los actores armados entonces empezamos
de nuevo a cultivar el campo a recuperar
las tierras a volver a cultivar a
reconstruir las viviendas que habían
sido quemadas las escuelas los centros
de salud
y reactivar toda la parte económica
recuperarlo en la educación
volverán
a mejorar los ingresos económicos para
las familias
de tal manera que pudimos ir poco a poco
haciendo retornos reactivando los
cultivos
hicimos todo el proceso ya con los años
la comercialización del cacao y poco a
poco mejorando estos ingresos entonces
pudimos
buscar comercialización
con kepa de alemania
con luz o la chs de inglaterra
y poco a poco hemos avanzado esto lo
logramos gracias
a las buenas prácticas que tenemos de
cuidar el medio ambiente
obtuvimos la certificación bio orgánica
y la certificación de comercio justo
para las exportaciones todo este trabajo
lo hemos hecho autónomamente como
comunidad
cuáles son los objetivos de nosotros esa
búsqueda pacífica en medio de la guerra
luchando por defender la vida por
defender el derecho a la tenencia de la
tierra
esos han sido
nuestra lucha y seguirá siendo hasta el
final
esto ha tenido unos costos muy grandes
para nosotros
por qué
estamos hablando de unos 350 miembros de
la comunidad asesinados
la persecución contra muchos de nosotros
que continúa
yo finalmente hoy estoy hablando aquí
mañana se conocerán de pronto mi
historia porque de pronto me matarán yo
vivo condenado sentenciado a muerte
entonces
eso ha pasado con muchos compañeros que
también han tenido la oportunidad de
hacer giras acá en europa en eeuu
y decir lo mismo o ya no están con
nosotros físicamente estos compañeros
hermanos de lucha que han muerto están
espiritualmente con nosotros y gracias a
ellos tenemos fuerza para continuar
porque era un capaz de ofrendar su vida
por eso que hemos creído
debemos defender la vida el derecho a la
tenencia de la tierra porque los
campesinos no tenemos otra opción no
tenemos empleo no tenemos nada que hacer
entonces
la tierra para nosotros es nuestra madre
y no vamos a dejar nuestra madre
entonces para todo esto la presencia
internacional de los grupos que nos
acompañan en terreno físicamente ha sido
muy importante porque son escoltas
civiles
son los que nos permiten movernos en las
zonas para todas las actividades para
poder cultivar para poder salir a la
ciudad y para movernos en el campo
porque si no lo hacemos de esta forma
pues es muy fácil que nos puedan
asesinar
lamentablemente es muy triste que en un
estado como el estado colombiano que
supuestamente es un estado democrático
pero que finalmente eso no es verdad
un estado democrático debe de defender
primero la vida de los ciudadanos
no quitarle la vida a sus propios
ciudadanos
es posible entonces
paso por paso
la lic
la corte interamericana
derechos humanos de las naciones unidas
pues nos ha dado todo el reconocimiento
la comisión interamericana de los
derechos humanos
la corte constitucional colombiana pues
también dio la sentencia de 10 25 en el
año 2007
intentando la seguridad el respeto a los
miembros de la comunidad de paz
las instituciones del estado colombiano
estos últimos gobiernos siempre las han
desacatado ante el desacato de la t-10
25 de la corte constitucional
la corte
emana el auto 164 intentando obligar a
las instituciones del estado colombiano
por la seguridad hacer justicia para
todos los crímenes
pero también ha sido desacatado esto es
una
situación
y así la entendemos nosotros como
comunidad un exterminio sistemático
decretado por el estado colombiano
contra nuestra comunidad
hemos trascendido todos los
y las esferas
todos estos casos ya han puesto en
conocimiento de todas las altas cortes
colombianas
como decía la comisión interamericana la
corte interamericana la corte
constitucional han fallado en favor de
la comunidad
pero todavía no hemos logrado el respeto
la persecución continúa como siempre
a pesar de que ahorita en el 2016
el acuerdo entre la guerrilla y el
estado colombiano
eso creó muchas expectativas de paz en
colombia'
pero finalmente la persecución continúa
porque es que el estado colombiano no le
interesa la paz y por eso el
incumplimiento a todos estos acuerdos y
por eso la persecución contra los
líderes sociales
los líderes indígenas afros o nosotros
los campesinos
estamos hablando de unos 500 líderes
asesinados en todo el país las amenazas
continúan
contra la comunidad de paz contra mí por
ejemplo en el 2012 cuando me hacen un
atentado de los tantos que me han hecho
he sufrido cuatro atentados donde
gracias a dios todavía estoy vivo y
gracias también como digo la presencia
internacional
que ha sido pues una ayuda muy grande
para nosotros
el 29 de diciembre del 2017 cuando entré
a un grupo de paramilitares
a la comunidad asesinar dos miembros del
consejo interno a nuestro representante
legal germán graciano foso y arroyo
lópez
re tuvimos dos de los paramilitares
armados de los cinco que ingresaron
lo retuvimos y entonces pedimos al alto
gobierno que tenía que presentarse para
entregárselo a ellos
finalmente después de dos días de
llegaron el viceministro del interior
y le entregamos a estos dos
paramilitares después de dos días
estaban en libertad
la fiscalía entonces les dice que no que
nos demandarán porque habíamos hecho una
retención ilegal
que ellos tenían todo el derecho era de
de mandarnos a nosotros
y las armas que le quitamos a los
trastos paramilitares las destruimos
entonces en presencia del defensor
nacional del defensor del pueblo
lo hicimos llegar allá y delante de él
destruimos eso
entonces es una situación bastante
difícil
gracias como digo a toda la solidaridad
internacional la fuerza que nos dan
porque cada carta que ustedes hacen al
gobierno cualquiera de las instituciones
cualquier mensaje que nos hacen llegar
eso nos da mucha fuerza porque no
estamos solos nos sentimos acompañados
y realmente
mientras estemos con la solidaridad
internacional va a ser muy difícil que
nos puedan exterminar
por eso
hoy
toda la audiencia
que está presente
porque creo que mis palabras llegarán a
muchos oyentes
de verdad que les pedimos
encarecidamente la solidaridad
porque vuelvo y repito a nosotros nos
tienen decretado al exterminio porque un
proceso como el de la comunidad de paz
ha sido el proceso más conocido a nivel
internacional pero la persecución es más
grande y simplemente lo que buscamos es
la defensa la vida el derecho a la
tierra
la justicia social como tal porque
sabemos que esto no es un problema
simplemente de la comunidad es un
problema de la humanidad
usted no lo sentimos como de nosotros
sino de la humanidad en general yo creo
que cualquier ser humano se sentiría
cobijado con esto entonces
hoy la memoria de nuestros compañeros
están con nosotros
yo quiero pedir a toda la audiencia
que no se escucha en el mundo
que realmente intercedan ante sus
gobiernos y que también interceda ante
el gobierno colombiano
para que pare esta barbarie
repito contra todas las comunidades
porque por ejemplo acaban de sacar el
ministro
de la defensa por todas las atrocidades
que se están cometiendo contra las
comunidades indígenas hacen una masacre
de jóvenes que quisieron ocultar cuando
la descubrieron eso le costó el papel al
ministro de la defensa
ya antes le había tocado al comandante
general de las fuerzas militares por
todas las atrocidades por todas las
violaciones a los derechos humanos que
se vienen cometiendo
hoy la presencia paramilitar en la zona
de urabá y en colombia puede no decir el
control social político y económico está
ligado al proyecto paramilitar del
estado colombiano amparado por
multinacionales
y quiero nombrar una de ellas la
chiquita brand
de los eeuu nosotros vimos los primeros
demandantes demandamos
porque obtuvimos documentos introducción
de armas introducción de municiones y
pagos directos a los paramilitares por
medio de una convivir una cooperativa de
seguridad privada en la zona de urabá
llamada papagayo en el municipio de
carepa
con esto la multinacional admitió parte
de responsabilidad pero no directamente
sino como indirectamente
como podría ser no responsable
directamente si trae armas de los eeuu y
municiones con que mataron a muchos
miembros de la comunidad de paz y muchos
en el país
entonces
luz solar es un ejemplo de
de empresa defensora de los derechos
humanos lo contrario de chiquita brands
por eso una forma hay formas de hacer
empresas hay formas alternativas
pero finalmente muy difícil
en colombia ahorita la agencia nacional
de tierras
está generando un banco de tierras para
las multinacionales para que exploten en
el carbón el petróleo represas
hidroeléctricas todo lo que sea
relatándonos la tierra a las comunidades
campesinas las comunidades indígenas y
las comunidades afros
y toda la excusa es que eso son cosas
del narcotráfico no es eso
el paramilitarismo y todas estas
empresas están ligadas a todo el
proyecto paramilitar y la
institucionalidad
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]